para las mujeres es tremendamente
importante en este momento que
este juez haya bloqueado esta ley texana
porque esta ley es inconstitucional
es por esta razón por la que el
departamento
de justicia de estadounidenses ha
decidido
traer esta demanda ante esta ley
entonces en este momento la ley estará
bloqueada lo que significa que podemos
continuar con la demanda está esta ley y
asegurar que las mujeres puedan volver a
exceder en texas y en todos los estados
unidos- a su derecho constitucional de
interrumpir el embarazo daniela sin
embargo se sabe que la medida del juez
es temporal que sigue y hasta dónde
puede llegar esta batalla judicial
correcto
lo que ha decidido determinado esta
decisión de los jueces es que en este
momento la ley será bloqueada de entrar
en vigencia
entonces esto es para permitir que la
demanda estatal
liberada por el departamento de justicia
llegue a su fin hasta llegar a la
suprema corte y en ese momento la
suprema corte deberá decidir nuevamente
sobre la constitucionalidad en el caso
la inconstitucionalidad de este de esta
ley texana que viola no solamente todo
el precedente de 1973 estableció por
broadway pero también los derechos
fundamentales de las mujeres
danny la cual sería una solución
definitiva a este pulso por el aborto
que se mantiene en los estados más
conservadores como texas por ejemplo
pues la decisión definitiva de la corte
suprema haga su trabajo y defiende la
constitución estadounidense y defiende
el precedente estadounidense que ya ha
sido determinado por broadway que
declara que la interrupción del embarazo
es un derecho legal constitucional de
todas personas estándar y toda mujer en
territorio estadounidense
mirando a nuestros colegas
latinoamericanos de la especial la corte
suprema mexicana que tomó una decisión
similar
por voto unánime hace menos de un mes
declarando que la criminalización del
aborto es inconstitucional porque atenta
contra los derechos humanos del empleo
daniela desde el women's de quality
center esta organización para la cual
usted trabaja cuál es el mensaje frente
a toda esta situación
el mensaje es que
puede ser asustador ver cómo se están
tratando de retroceder los derechos de
las mujeres
a eeuu quisiera que todo el mundo mirará
américa latina donde en menos de un año
argentina ha
legalizado el aborto
méxico a través de su corte suprema
hasta dos semanas y media de screaming
él descriminalizó el aborto y en este
momento en colombia está
debatiendo ante la corte suprema una
propuesta de criminalizar el aborto en
su totalidad también lo que significa
que existe un movimiento y un momento
para proteger y defender los derechos de
las mujeres y de las personas constantes
en toda américa latina lo que significa
también esto puede apoyar a la lucha en
estado daniela martínez directora de
estrategia y comunicaciones del women's
de cuadri centre muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france 24